[Música]
en tu casa no me quiere
porque me vivo cantando me dicen que soy
mariachi
y que no tengo para cuándo
y el mariachi fue declarado patrimonio
cultural inmaterial de la humanidad en
el año 2011 hemos tenido la oportunidad
de conocer gente de otros países
hay mariachis en japón hay mariachis en
españa hay mariachis en centroamérica
en estados unidos hay mariachis en
croacia que ni siquiera hablan en
español
y viven de la música de mariachi se
ponen un traje de charro y lo hacen de
una manera magistral como mariachi
imperial azteca hemos tenido la fortuna
de cantar en otros países ante gente que
ni siquiera habla nuestro idioma es
fascinante escuchar como corean el
cielito lindo te ven vestido de charro y
traen vestido de mexico
se arriman contigo te pidieron una foto
hemos llegado a sentir que somos sus
ídolos desafortunadamente en nuestro
país en medio
la historia cambia completamente por eso
empecé con esta frase del maestro cuco
sánchez
me dicen que soy mariachi y que no tengo
para cuando me dibuja perfectamente el
como la mayoría no todos pero la mayoría
de la sociedad mexicana ven a los
mariachis observaría y es sinónimo de no
tener para cuando de no tener dinero de
no tener ilusiones se nos ha llegado a
tachar de borrachos que le pasa de edad
la verdad es que no somos unas peras en
dulces pero estamos aquí ante todos
ustedes para tratar poquito de cambiar
esa imagen que se tiene del mariachi
porque hay otra otra cara de la moneda
que qué es la que vale la pena el que la
mayoría de la sociedad tenga presente
sobre todo las nuevas generaciones son
años y años de música mexicana en donde
están involucrados arreglistas
compositores cantautores intérpretes
músicos de mariachi que se han partido
plomo por lograr algo que han logrado y
que y que a pocos se les recordó que es
es darle identidad a mexico a través de
un género musical que es el mariachi
huelva ya ni siquiera ha sido fácil
convencer a nuestra propia gente a
nuestra gente más allegada que el ser
mariachi vale la pena y para muestra
tenemos varios botones
hace mucho tiempo yo andaba de novio con
la que hoy es mi esposa
efe
me invita a un convivo con su familia es
se presenta con todos yo muy orgulloso
muy
total de que después de rato llegar no
señora a su tía y sería joven
usted me parece muy buena gente gracia
y todo esto qué se dedica soy mariachi
la sonrisa el y por acá atrás el tío muy
empezamos mal
me aburro completamente
pero con el tiempo a través de viajes
con la música de mariachi mis compañeros
acompañando artistas giras nacionalmente
internacionalmente también
este un cambio de idea
ahora bien diferente a lo que es ser
mariachi
les aseguro que anécdotas como estas mis
compañeros tienen muchas yo recuerdo una
que aunque en su momento me causó
tristeza y enojo ahora está me da risa
el día de mi boda
llega mi esposa al templo y ya saben la
típica tía va a la brasa pero ésta se
pone a llorar
yo me imaginaba que lloraba de alegría
porque se estaba casando
la sobrina consentida o la mayor no sé
después me enteré que si estaba llorando
porque se iba a casar
pero porque se iba a casar con un
mariachi
quisiera saber a quién le daremos esa
familia
pero bueno mejor les platico de la otra
cara de la moneda
el mariachi imperial azteca se fundó el
16 de noviembre del 2005
me siento muy afortunado de pertenecer a
esta agrupación
porque a base de esfuerzo de trabajo y
de mucha mucha dedicación creo que hemos
logrado cambiado un poco el concepto que
la gente tiene de nosotros siento que
ahora nos ven con más respeto y por qué
no decirlo hasta con admiración
pero además
el mariachi imperial azteca nos ha dado
la oportunidad de vivir experiencias que
jamás imaginamos
aunque son muchas hay tres que para mí
han sido las más significativas
en el 2011 tuvimos el honor de ser el
mariachi oficial en la gira del relevo
de la antorcha de los juegos
panamericanos guadalajara-2011
precisamente
nos presentamos
[Aplausos]
en las capitales de los 32 estados de la
república mexicana con esto estábamos
logrando
que nuestro nombre y nuestro trabajo
trascendiera más allá de los límites del
estado pero además que los empresarios
ya no solamente voltearon a guadalajara
oa la ciudad de mexico donde por
tradición se dice que están los mejores
mariachis sino que ahora mirarán hacia
provincia y precisamente aquí
aguascalientes
[Aplausos]
también
en el 2010
y 2018
gracias a un gran gran amigo que tenemos
vimos realizado nuestro sueño de viajar
trabajar y conocer otros países
específicamente francia y españa
pero
en el 2017 sucedió algo
que yo ni en el mejor de mi sueño
imagina
recibimos un inbox del instituto
mexicano del mariachi en la ciudad de
mexico donde nos decían
que habían escuchado nuestra producción
en spotify y que para ellos cumplía con
los requisitos necesarios para que lo
estuviéramos al grammy latino
aunque al principio me hacemos que era
una broma investigamos y así lo hicimos
cuál es nuestra sorpresa que después de
cinco meses nos llaman nuestro manager y
nos dice
señores felicidades
han sido nominados al latin grammy
y esto entre más de 80 inscritos de
nuestro género
así nos estábamos convirtiendo en el
primer grupo hidrocálido en lograr dicha
nominación
de verdad
de verdad yo no sé si a esto se le puedo
llamar tener éxito para mí
el verdadero éxito fue después de esta
noche
aunque un poco triste
regresar a mi casa
que me recibiera mi esposa
y mis hijos
me abrazaron y me dijeron
para para levantar la cara y sonríe
estamos muy orgullosos de ti y para
nosotros tú eres el ganador
seguro estoy
que por todas estas cosas merece la pena
ser mariachi
y es así que buscando la manera en que
valga la pena ser mariachi es que vengo
aguascalientes
porque hablar del mariachi imperial
azteca
precisamente es hablar también de
aguascalientes los primeros días fueron
muy difíciles porque no conocía a nadie
ni siquiera músicos de otras
agrupaciones de mariachi que no
aguascalientes pero yo tenía un
propósito
y mi propósito era conocer al mariachi
imperial azteca porque
en mis inicios como mariachi que ya me
quería dedicar bien al mariachi escuché
un álbum que tenían ellos que se llama
en tu sonrisa lo cual para mí fue
wow o sea me gustaría estar en mesa
mariachi quisiera conocerlo a ellos
fue algo para mí que si quería alcanzar
ese sueño tenía que caminar hacia donde
precisamente está aquí para mi suerte
pasa que me invitan a trabajar en una
semana tres días para que ellos me
conocieran
y allí pasó algo muy curioso porque éste
aceptó que tenía bastantes nervios
porque era un mariachi que yo tenía en
mi mente que tal vez será muy difícil
pero bueno acepté y mi sorpresa fue que
pasó algo muy curioso en el primer día
fue que
al acercarme a ellos y cada uno me
estrecha su mano
me di cuenta
de que eran grandes personas grandes
seres humanos ellos tanto fue que me
dieron mucha confianza
tanta fuerza confianza que me hicieron
sentir que ya pertenecía a esta
agrupación sin todavía aún serlo
pues bueno pasaron esos tres días me
regreso a san luís
y mi suerte todavía continuaba porque a
los pocos días me hablaron para decirme
que si podía estar en esta agrupación
pero tenía que vivir venirme a vivir
aquí aguascalientes yo soy de las
personas que creo oportunidades y hay
muchas pero pocas son las que nosotros
queremos tener
y para mí fue una de esas y la cual
entonces yo la acepté y hoy en día estoy
muy agradecido por eso porque los
mejores momentos que ha pasado el
mariachi imperial azteca me ha tocado
vivirlas y también lo que les puedo
decir es que son grandes amigos pero más
que eso una gran familia
y hablando de amigos los amigos del
mariachi imperial azteca yo quiero
hablar de algunos unas personalidades
quiero empezar con uno que creo yo
ha sido el parteaguas para la
trascendencia musical de nosotros estoy
hablando del matador de toros josé tomás
josé tomás de cliente a amigo y como
buen amigo nos invita a hacer una gira
en su país en españa
para llevar un pedacito de méjico a esas
personitas que necesitan de cuidados
especiales
esta gira llamada igual que nuestra
producción discográfica en tu sonrisa
estuvimos el toledo en bilbao cádiz y
madrid tocando en las instalaciones para
toda esa gente bonita posteriormente y
conservando la amistad del matador
estuvimos en el 2018
en nimes francia
fuimos a uno de los teatros más
importantes de burgos estuvimos en una
discoteca muy famosa de madrid joy
eslava y todo con el mismo fin al
beneficio de estas personas con una
experiencia maravillosa
pero en esta gira en el 2018
otro evento que que estuvimos ahí nos
deja sin aliento es haber estado en el
cumpleaños del señor joaquín sabina
ahí imagínense nosotros tocando y
cantando las canciones de joaquín sabina
y joaquín sabina cantando las canciones
de josé alfredo jiménez
inolvidable en ese evento también estuvo
joan manuel serrat
tuvimos la oportunidad de tomarnos la
fotografía de saludarlos como músicos
como intérpretes
y pues fue algo fenomenal como dice por
allá
otra de las personas que les quiero
platicar es el señor armando manzanero
armando manzanero que en un día decide
llevarle una serenata a su esposa y les
pregunta a sus amigos recomienden el
mariachi el mejor de aguascalientes le
dicen pues hablarle al imperial azteca
tan así lo creyó el señor que nos confía
una producción discográfica para una
cantante de guadalajara y queda él muy
satisfecho con nuestro trabajo
no hace mucho tiempo
este grabamos una versión de un tema
de un tema de un rockero español miguel
ríos
siendo sergio vallín el guitarrista de
maná el contacto directo para la
grabación de este tema este tema es
parte de la banda sonora de una película
mexicana miguel ríos participa en ella y
le propone a la producción que venga al
mariachi a
que grabé la escena
y este nos hablan por teléfono quedamos
en un acuerdo
nos vamos a la ciudad de mexico y
participamos en la escena
y todo esto pues yo creo que no es por
nuestra cara bonita ni nuestro cuerpo
atlético
y precisamente
precisamente como no es por arte de
magia el éxito se puede definir de
muchas maneras pero imagínense que antes
de todo esto uno se queda sin trabajo
entonces uno tiene que buscar la forma
sería adelante la vida no se detiene y
esto es una vorágine gigantesca vivimos
en una selva muy grande mi director me
decía algún día cuando estés deprimido
vente a trabajar y si te olvida algún
día un compañero me vio muy triste y
cabizbajo me dijo que tienes te veo mal
porque estás tan mal es que creo que no
soy lo suficiente para esta agrupación y
me dice bueno si te exigen quiere decir
que eres suficiente entonces échale
ganas no pasa nada y así podríamos
hablar de miles de historias y cientos
de anécdotas que tenemos como mariachis
con los cientos de clientes que hay todo
el tiempo pero el éxito podemos
definirlo de muchas maneras pero yo creo
en realidad que cuando pensamos que
hemos alcanzado el éxito no es así
apenas estamos comenzando
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a la feria de saltos de mérito más
calientes van llegando los salientes con
su genio para perdón sino 30 por el
brazo al colar de la partida a jugarse
hasta la vida hoy la menor es colón
rinda la pelea de gallos con su público
verdadero con sus chorros de dinero y
los gritos de gritos reposando les dé
gusto no se siente ni las horas con
tequila encantadoras que son puro
corazón
[Música]
unidad
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
gracias